i want to talk about this you have an up
because i'm excited about it you've been
talking about it for a while and you
talk about yourself a lot
it's an upcoming hulu series with uh the
great steve martin
and um it's
and the great and the great selena gomez
selena gomez is on the show
yeah uh and and i know that you you work
a lot with steve martin how's
this project going it's it's it's called
only murders
in the building and it's crossed between
the odd couple and dateline
yeah um no we've been waiting for that
one
it's a murder mystery uh it it drops as
the kids say
um august 31 and uh very much like steve
martin at the urinal
it streams for 36 hours
[Applause]
all right very
selena was so fat you know she
she was very embarrassed the first day
of shooting she made a horrible football
she went up to steve and said
i'm such a big fan judy dench and so
you know but then they bonded you know
because when steve gets talking about
banjo playing techniques you know we're
all just riveted
here you're going uh i mean you do this
incredible road show obviously
everything had to shut down
uh for the pandemic but you do this
amazing show
which you have guested for you guys and
it was
uh i have to just insert these things
for the transcript later uh
and um and anyway uh you and steve
martin work together and
just the way you go after steve you go
after each other with insults but it's
absolutely delightful it's one of the
funniest shows i've ever seen oh thank
you
it's great you know steve is endlessly
creative he's always writing
he he never gets any writer's block as
much as we pray for it he doesn't
he's one of the most sensitive you know
people
you know in the world that you would
meet i mean you you can't
you know it's what's amazing about
stephen this is true and he'd be
embarrassed if i said that
said this but every time we go to a
restaurant
he knows the first name of the waitress
it doesn't matter what restaurant we are
what's amazing is that a he knows their
name and b that they're all named doll
face
so i
steve is one of the funniest guys you
know when before i met steve
i just bring this up because this is how
brilliantly funny and original he's been
his whole life
i remember it was like 1980 i never met
him
and i'm watching television the grammys
and he presents
the best comedy album of
the year and he comes out in full
tuxedo tales and no pants
boxer underwear garters socks
and he doesn't mention it and he just
starts and the nominations are
and he starts reading it and finally a
little
man with a pair of pants comes running
out on a hanger
and steve looks in and says well it's
about time
genius the man's a genius he's a genius
uh i want to congratulate you on a human
note you are
a grandfather and uh this is very
exciting news i mean
oliver's out there oliver's here
where are you wally there you are he
does not want to be seen
oliver wanted to sit as far away from
you as possible
no no i have a 17 month old a grandson
theodore
and uh ollie and his beautiful wife
alissa are expecting this july their
second son that's exciting and my son
henry is expecting his first son in
september i'll have three
boys under two and it's and it's great
to hear the little pitter-patter of
little feet you know it's like
when david spade comes up